conventionnel merci la parole et à
monsieur claude goasguen pardon ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
affaires étrangères pour lui demander
d'expliquer l'inexplicable
les raisons qui ont conduit la france a
voté le 16 avril en faveur d'une
résolution présentée par divers pays
musulmans au conseil exécutif de
l'unesco
ainsi depuis le 16 avril le mont du
temple à jérusalem et d'autres édifices
religieux juif situé également à
jérusalem doivent être considérées comme
des lieux saints exclusivement musulman
plusieurs questions monsieur le ministre
de quel droit l'unesco qui est chargé de
la culture et qui d'ailleurs devrait
s'en occuper davantage du côté de la
palestine avec les manifestations
antisémites
de quel droit l'unesco décide de
modifier l'histoire
de quel droit l'unesco s'arroge tel le
droit de prendre une décision politique
qui ne peut d'ailleurs qu'envenimer les
temps sur locales et de ce point de vue
à se substituer au conseil de sécurité
de l'onu en votant cette résolution sur
le ministre en votant cette résolution
vous avez rompu avec toute l'édition et
historique de la france vous trouvé
isolé au milieu de toutes les grandes
démocraties occidentales
et je n'ose imaginer les raisons
économiques qui ont pu pousser à faire
cet acte mais je vous dis la france
c'est désormais elle s'est déshonorée en
participant à une opération de
négationnisme culturel qui n'appliquent
pas seulement israël mais l'ensemble de
l'humanité monsieur le ministre le mont
du temple n'est pas seulement un des
fondements de la culture juive
mais c'est aussi un des fondements de la
culture chrétienne le mont du temple est
liée à l'histoire de l'humanité il est
lié à toutes nos civilisations sans
exception par votre vote
la france a promu l'intolérance nous ne
l'accepterons pas je souhaite que le
gouvernement dans les plus brefs délais
puis se rectifier ce vote qui nous happe
déshonorait
la parole est à monsieur jean marc
ayrault ont mis des affaires étrangères
et du développement international
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député claude goasguen jour merci de
m'avoir posé cette question
vous l'avez fait avec le ton qui vous
convient je voudrais vous rappeler mais
vous le savez fort bien que chaque année
l'unesco examine et approuve une
résolution de ce type depuis plusieurs
années je vous invite d'ailleurs à
regarder attentivement les textes et les
comparer donc vous me donnez l'occasion
de préciser la position de la france
je vais le faire et rien dans le vote de
la france ne doit être interprétée comme
une remise en cause de la présence et de
l'histoire juive à jérusalem
s'il y a une incompréhension du fait de
certaines formulations dans cette
résolution
je le regrette car la position de la
france sur la question de jérusalem est
clair ne varie pas et ne variera pas
c'est la défense de la liberté d'accès
de culte à jérusalem ville fondamental
pour les trois grandes religions
monothéistes et qui appartient à tous
les croyants juifs chrétiens et
musulmans comme elle l'a déjà fait par
le passé la france a voté ce texte avec
d'autres pays européens
pour marquer son attachement au statu
quo sur les lieux saints à jérusalem
et cette position est essentielle dans
le contexte actuel de la montée des
tensions que vous connaissez et que nous
regrettons et du blocage des
négociations entre les israéliens et les
palestiniens
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
la france a pris une initiative
politique qui est difficile de réunir le
30 mai une réunion ministérielle nous
efforcerons de trouver des solutions
pour rapprocher les différentes
positions retrouver les voies du
dialogue et je vous invite à approuver
la démarche de la france merci